argyle the gentle stoner eddie the
dungeon master victor the boogeyman
stranger thanks has always had great
characters and season four is no
exception keep watching for a rundown of
the newest members of this iconic cast
warning spoilers ahead
we meet eddie munson in the cafeteria of
hawkins high where he initially comes
off as kind of a jerk eddie runs a
hellfire club a role-playing game group
our protagonists have joined since our
old dungeon master will moved west mike
and dustin are genuinely worried about
breaking the news that lucas won't be
joining them for the culmination of
eddie's dungeons and dragons campaign
and when they finally tell him he
doesn't take it well eddie appears to be
a proud troublemaking loser who brags
about having not graduated the year
before but this first impression is
designed to throw us off balance
welcome to hellfire
eddie isn't a saint but he's also not
the devil that most of hawkins will soon
believe him to be
once we learn more about the dungeon
master of hellfire club he becomes a
much more likable character when
troubled cheerleader chrissy meets him
in the woods to buy drugs they bond over
shared insecurities chrissy acts like
she doesn't know him then remembers he
used to be a quiet kid with short hair
who like to play guitar when they go to
his uncle's trailer we can tell that
life has been rough for eddie munson he
clearly doesn't have much family or many
resources and his etching personality is
probably a defense mechanism
however his life's about to get a lot
rougher as most of hawkins suspects him
of being a double possessed serial
killer
jason carver is pretty much the exact
opposite of eddie munson a golden boy
with perfectly quaffed blonde locks
jason is the captain of the hawkins high
basketball team like eddie we meet him
while he delivers an impassioned speech
to his classmates however while eddie
rages against conformity jason rallies
the student body to his conformist point
of view his pre-championship tournament
pep talk is full of the empty rhetoric
that often follows real world tragedies
what did they die for for us to lose to
some some crap school
jason also makes sure to publicly
profess his love for chrissy the fact
that she stands him up later that night
might have nothing to do with their
relationship or it might be a red flag
that things aren't so perfect between
the cheerleader and the jock we soon see
that jason's good guy persona is as much
a facade as eddie's bad boy act he
doesn't see himself as a law breaker but
he doesn't think twice about breaking
into someone else's property to party or
bragging about underage drinking in
front of the cops
he also has a violent temper he beats up
eddie's bandmate to get information and
seems poised to do worse if he ever
catches up to eddie the end of season 4
volume 1 reinforces that eddie and jason
are indeed diametrically opposed once
jason has witnessed vekna in action he
goes all in on the satanic panic and
blames the hellfire club for the murders
the audience might see him for who he is
but hawkins is still mostly on their
golden boy's side
argyle is the only friend jonathan has
made since moving to california he's a
delivery driver for surfer boy pizza and
a gentle stoner whose product of choice
is purple palm tree delight why do you
just go to the van
and do your thing
argyle's a supportive best bud who
actively listens to jonathan's concerns
about nancy and gives him sound advice
but it doesn't seem cut out for the kind
of hijinks that will and jonathan always
seem to get into
more weed is that really a good idea
right now have you got a better idea to
keep him calm
take for example when jonathan will and
mike scheme to order some surfer boy pie
so that he can arrive at the buyer's
house and rescue them as they're
basically being held under house arrest
by dr rowan and dr brunner's goons
however the military gets there first
and argyle finds himself in the middle
of a gunfight he barely keeps it
together when an injured guard dies in
the back of his vehicle while fleeing
and he loses his mind as they're burying
the man in the desert though jonathan
tries to explain that the point of an
unmarked grave is to hide the dead body
empathetic argyle imagines that he must
have had a family and makes a makeshift
tombstone out of a pizza box when the
group road trips to susie's house to
tracel's location mike warns argyle that
they're very religious he takes offense
and says he's spiritual too more proof
that argyle is a lover and not a fighter
he instantly falls for eden susie's
foul-mouthed older sister
we should probably hate this season's
otherworldly evil monster the most but
angela gives vecna a run for his money
in her letters to mike elle makes it
seem like things are going swimmingly
since she's moved to california but will
knows better it's not just that l is an
unpopular wallflower she's the target of
intense bullying at her high school and
angela is the ringleader of the mean
kids circus like jason angela manages to
get away with pretty vile behavior while
for the most part staying on the good
side of the authority figures around her
she gives an insufferable slideshow
presentation about why helen keller is
her hero and turns around and torments a
differently abled kid in her class when
she interrupts l as she explains her
diorama of hopper's house it's obvious
that the teacher is aware that angela is
a bit of a pill however she doesn't do
anything to protect l even as the kids
are snickering about her dead father
figure
i made
a dirayama
of our cabin more like diarrhea
in short order angela demonstrates the
full extent of her cruelty first by
tripping her leading to her project
being destroyed l doesn't snitch but the
truth is so obvious that angela gets
reprimanded as revenge angela
orchestrates a humiliating skating rink
attack which is made even worse by the
fact that elle lied to mike and told him
that she and angela were friends
nobody deserves a roller skate to the
face but seeing angela with a bloody
nose is a little satisfying we don't
know if we'll check in with this meanest
of mean girls again in volume 2 but it's
doubtful she learned her lesson
on the surface chrissy is an idealized
girl next door time with her bouncy
ponytail wide eyes and bright smile she
hits the part of head cheerleader and
the basketball team captain's girlfriend
however when max crosses pass with
chrissy first coming out of the guidance
counselor's office looking upsets then
in the bathroom we know something is
amiss the way chrissy holds her stomach
as she's leaving miss kelly's room
suggests that maybe she's pregnant only
moments later we see what's really going
on chrissy is bulimic as she's purging
she begins to hallucinate monstrous feet
then she hears her mother's voice the
sound bites seem like snippets from
chrissy's past her mom was apparently
critical of her weight and put far too
much emphasis on looks chrissy soon
snaps out of it and comes back to
reality worse for the wearer though
chrissy does smile at jason during the
pep rally in a way that implies she
returns his affection the fact that she
stands him up could mean that she felt
the same kind of pressure from him she
visits eddie shortly after hoping he can
sell her something to make the pain go
away chrissy who is extremely fragile at
this point confides in eddie that she
feels like she's losing her mind she and
eddie have a kind of chemistry that for
a few minutes in episode 1 makes the
audience think they could be something
unfortunately the cheerleader with a
dark secret doesn't have much time left
fred benson works with nancy on the
hawkins high school newspaper he's
trying hard to fill the vacancy that
nancy's boyfriend and former reporting
partner jonathan left when he moved to
california
you're not jonathan clearly not
too bad for nerdy fred his flirtation
comes off more like antagonization nancy
doesn't respond well to his negative
attitude or his judgment of jonathan
even though nancy's his senior in the
superior journalist he doesn't show her
much respect but whether or not nancy
likes him or his writing is the least of
fred's problems when a cop comes to the
car window to see what fred and nancy
are doing at a crime scene fred
experiences the same hallucinations that
plagued chrissy just before her death in
fred's case he relives a car accident in
which the other passenger was killed
vecna in the form of the officer implies
that fred was responsible for the fiery
crash
around the same time max breaks into the
guidance counselor's office to look for
information in chrissy's file she
discovers that fred was seeing the
counselor too and suffering from the
same symptoms before he and nancy finish
interviewing the witnesses fred succumbs
to his visions and goes missing beck now
forces him to join the ranks of his
guilt-ridden lost souls after he
levitates and crushes him in the middle
of the highway
whether it's because they love him or
fear him jason's teammates follow him as
if he really is their leader when he
goes after eddie the prime suspect and
his girlfriend's murder all of them
including lucas join him lucas's loyalty
may have been torn early on but once he
watches jason turn violent he sticks
around to protect his friends another
teammate patrick also looks conflicted
as jason's behavior becomes increasingly
problematic however patrick has other
things weighing on his mind
patrick thinks he's cursed
once max goes through miss kelly's files
the hawkins kids and the audience know
that vechna picks on teenagers who have
trauma in their pasts we never see what
happened to patrick to make him
vulnerable to vector's curse but we do
see becknet take possession of patrick's
mind as jason's posse rides in his car
which results in a nosebleed not long
after patrick spots the telltale
grandfather clock from the creel house
at chrissy's funeral when his teammates
finally figure out where eddie's been
hiding jason swims after eddie who's
trying to row away in a speedboat that
won't start patrick still looks
conflicted and we can't tell if he's
trying to help jason catch at you or
stop him from doing something he'll
regret but before patrick can reach them
becna pulls him under the surface of
lover's leg then lifts him high into the
air and kills him just as he did chrissy
right in front of jason's eyes rather
than prove to jason that eddie is
innocent the basketball captain is now
sure the dungeon master had something to
do with the death of his girlfriend and
his teammate
when joyce discovers a ransom note and
the russian doll that came in the mail
she enlists murray to help her figure
out her next move the message is from
someone who calls themselves enzo which
happened to be the name of the
restaurant where hopper and joyce were
supposed to go on a date only she and
hopper would know that convincing joyce
that jim might still be alive she and
murray contact enzo record the
conversation determined from the ambient
talk that enzo is a prison guard and
agreed to an exchange in alaska forty
thousand dollars for hopper's life
enzo's real name is dimitri and though
he has to play the part of a sadistic
guard he's keeping his fingers crossed
that his prisoner can beat the odds and
make it outside of the prison walls
unfortunately for hopper and himself
dimitri seems pretty green when it comes
to covert operations his go-between
double crosses him and secures a better
deal with the russian government for
exposing his duplicitousness that means
dimitri and hopper end up in a cell
together they aren't exactly friends but
necessity makes them allies they and a
handful of their fellow prisoners are
all but sentenced to death in a fight
against the demogorgon hopper knows
demogorgons hate fire so with an assist
from joyce and murray in the control
room he and dmitry managed to slip away
from the monster in the nick of time and
joyce and hopper are finally reunited
enzo gives joyce and murray instructions
to fly to alaska where they're supposed
to deliver the forty thousand dollars to
a pilot for hire and peanut butter
smuggler named yuri upon meeting him
murray proclaims that he doesn't really
care for the guy maybe that's because
yuri and murray have a lot in common
they're both big personalities with odd
senses of humor who get involved in some
seriously dangerous shenanigans
i don't like him
at first it seems like the outlandish
plan to free hopper from a russian
prison might work however yuri soon
realizes that a turncoat and three
american prisoners are worth more than
one and he switches sides
azuri transports murray and joyce to the
prison they cut their bindings with
glass from a broken peanut butter jar
and a comical mid-air fight ensues
murray comes out on top and his new plan
is to impersonate yuri while
infiltrating the prison since yuri and
murray bear strong resemblance to each
other in appearance and personality the
plan works at least the first step is a
success now yuri joyce and murray are
all inside the facility along with
hopper and dimitri not to mention a
demogorgon pickle goofy yuri will likely
see how the wind blows and buddy up with
whoever can help him or pay him the most
stranger things four tells the story of
the creel family several times and there
are important discrepancies in each
retelling nancy first hears about them
from eddie's uncle who heard it through
the once common urban legend that victor
creel mercilessly murdered his wife and
two kids by breaking their limbs and
cutting out their eyes when nancy and
robin go to the local library to search
through microfilm they happen upon a
tabloid from 1959 in which victor creole
claims demons killed his loved ones
wanting to hear the truth straight from
the source nancy and robin disguise
themselves as psychology students and
request an interview with the now
elderly and imprisoned victor creel
his account seems to confirm the kid's
suspicions his family bought the big
blue house and were very happy there for
about a month then upsetting
supernatural phenomena started to occur
victor believes his home in hawkins was
haunted by a demon who tortured and
killed his wife virginia and daughter
alice while it kept him occupied with
nightmarish visions his son henry he
says was found in a coma and died days
later victor was so destroyed by what
the supposed demon had wrought that he
gouged his own eyes out and hopes it
would take him too he's a shell of a man
when nancy and robin come to question
him and as of yet he doesn't know the
real story of what happened
one of the more confusing elements of
stranger things 4 is all the various
uniformed agencies pursuing 11. after
jane hopper concusses the bully angel
over the skate the local police show up
at the buyer's house to take ellen to
custody meanwhile lieutenant colonel
sullivan arrives at dr owen's personal
residence in nevada he plays nice at
first but then he lets owens in on the
real reason for his surprise middle of
the night helicopter visit the us
military thinks the hawkins lab was
training kids like 11 to be remote
assassins and the suspect l not eddie
actually killed chrissy and fred owens
swears she's dead but sullivan ransacks
the house and intends to tail him if he
goes looking for 11. dr owens gets to l
first when his people intercept her on
her way to juvie sullivan's thugs aren't
far behind they open fire at the buyer's
house with little concern as to whether
the kids are collateral damage
sullivan himself later interrogates a
guard who survived the shootout to get
the underground lab's location when
episode 7 ends he has the information he
needs but so do mike will jonathan and
argyle who are all headed to the same
place on the map
jamie campbell bower is credited with
playing peter ballard on stranger things
but he's actually playing a kind of
quadruple role that serves as the fourth
season's big reveal
sometimes
papa doesn't tell the truth
eleven meets ballard in the memories she
revisits thanks to the nina machine
where he's a lowly lab assistant who
occasionally stands up for her ballard
earns her trust and promises to help her
escape but really he just needs l to
remove the device preventing him from
harnessing his powers that's because
ballard is the mythical one that dr
brenner claims doesn't exist
he not l committed the hawkins lap
massacre but that's not all one is also
henry the son of victor creel henry
seems to have demonstrated a proclivity
for evil since early in his childhood
since a family moved to hawkins to try
and rid him of his demons we know that
hawkins in the lab aren't specifically
tied to his predicament or the upside
down
the young henry creel resented his
parents for trying to make him conform
when they seek the help of a doctor he
kills his mom and sister in the same way
becna disposes of his victims and frames
his dad for their incomprehensibly
gruesome murders in the aftermath he
ends up confined to the hawkins lab
anyway where l used her powers to send
him into the upside down where he
transforms into this season's big bad
beckham this development ties up a lot
of loose ends from seasons one through
three but whether we call him peter
ballard one henry creel or vecna his
story isn't over yet
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]